[Musique]
pour brut je vais vous raconter une
histoire de sart farès une secouriste
libanaise de 27 ans 153 d'amarrage votre
[Musique]
temps
elle était comme on dit ça on en
français suggère pour la joueuse a été
courageuse c'est son destin
sahar est né à beyrouth en 1993 dans une
famille modeste et chrétienne elle est
l'aînée des trois filles et elle adore
s'occuper de ses deux soeurs maria et
nagham à l'âge de 15 ans parce qu'elle
aime aider les autres elle intègre une
école d'infirmières à beyrouth
[Musique]
trois ans plus tard elle obtient son
diplôme elle commence à travailler dans
les hôpitaux de la capitale
elle a 21 ans quand elle rencontre
gilbert il tombe très vite amoureux et
décide de se fiancer deux ans plus tard
sarah 23 ans quand elle s'engage en tant
que volontaire auprès des pompiers de
beyrouth pour être sur le terrain dans
un milieu masculin
elle s'impose très vite grâce à son
courage et à sa volonté elle
impressionne tout le monde dans sa
caserne
rien d'étonnant à ce que des reflets
téléthon
[Musique]
d'arrêter les fonds du tarp mais quel
téléphone aux jo de salt sarraf non
seulement à dire de celle ci mahboub on
est en 2020 c'est l'année de son mariage
avec gilbert mais rien ne va se passer
comme prévu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le 4 août 2020 sahara est à sa caserne
il est 17 heures 50 quand les pompiers
reçoivent une alerte incendie
à un moment donné on a eu un appel pour
la chambre d'opérations qu'il ya des
grands à fumée qui sort de dépôt qui se
trouvent aux pôles
là ils ont envoyé les premiers
intervenants avec un wagon de feu un
wagon de l'ambulance
et un nombre des pompiers qui est neuf
font qu'une infirmière l'infirmière de
garde ce jour-là caezar gilbert a
accepté de me raconter ce qu'il s'est
passé après que les vidéos comme à
wimbledon
bagdad les marquettois la caméra de
cleves vie et d'avoir lâché becker au
tout départ là pour les vidéos
[Musique]
et elle l'a fait de creuser le chouchou
jeu seuil graphique année sera effectuée
très différent de la région nous chante
alors ça va ils sont trente d'attirer
les affiches de cette lan avec des stars
avec son v6 à nous faire à damas du
canard laqué de paris à l'acadie
[Musique]
ça y est
immédiatement après l'explosion gilbert
part au port pour essayer de retrouver
sa fiancée
sauf que quand ils arrivent sur place
c'est le chaos total tous les bâtiments
sont détruits et à la place de
l'entrepôt il découvre un cratère
il cherche alors sarre dans tous les
hôpitaux de beyrouth mais ne la retrouve
pas ça criait
la tête de l'étoile ould chafi monotonie
infos 03 chine asean à hanoï au sahara
clouds m
[Musique]
sahar est morte sur le coup en même
temps que tous les membres de son équipe
la cause de cet énorme déflagration
c'est la présence sur place de plusieurs
tonnes de nitrate d'ammonium un produit
chimique hautement explosif
quand vous avez reçu l'appel vous
n'étiez absolument pas au courant que
dans l'entrepôt il y avait du nitrate
d'ammonium non est-ce que quoi qu'il
arrive vous auriez pu faire quelque
chose non c'est une bombe et est prête à
n'importe quelle oeuvre a éclaté donc
votre équipe a été envoyée une mort
certaine
on peut dire ça on peut dire ça
[Musique]
au liban sarr et ses collègues sont
désormais considérés comme des héros la
jeune secouriste a été enterré dans le
village de sa famille située pas très
loin de la frontière syrienne
ils ont accepté que je les accompagne
sur place
nathalie cheryl
à l'arrivée le code barre et que j'aime
bien ça à faire et à surveiller les
louer aux sujets à alward et l'effet
rattrapage à 300 kg
[Musique]
eh oui
oh
et
me connaît
[Musique]
où
pour elle
[Musique]
oui
m
[Musique]
il y eu